born from the minds of a New York comedy
troupe called the tenderloins
Impractical Jokers has been a reliable
hit for truTV since debuting in December
2011
each episode consists of a series of
challenges and des in which four friends
bust each other's chops by embarrassing
one of their own
usually in public while hidden cameras
capture it all the goal good-natured
humiliation or featuring comic
improvisation in a real-world setting
[Music]
after annual cruises world tours and the
embarrassment themed TBS gameshow the
misery index Joe Murr Q and Sal are
moving from the small screen to the big
screen when Impractical Jokers the movie
hits theaters on February 21st 2020 but
what do you need to know before heading
in if you've watched the show you know
that the average episode is constructed
but not scripted the dares conceived by
the tenderloins forced them to use her
improv skills in unusual situations both
to make some good TV and to avoid a
punishment at the end of the episode
Impractical Jokers a movie takes the
basic concept of the series and blows it
up to big screen levels the official
synopsis a humiliating highschool mishap
from 1992 that sends the Impractical
Jokers on the road and hidden-camera
challenges for the chance to turn back
the clock and find redemption the movies
December 2019 trailer shows that this
early nineties element is provided by 90
superstar Paula Abdul he beats the
Jokers and invites them to a big party
in Miami but not all of them get to go
they decide the best way to determine
the odd man out is to do what they
always do stage elaborate competitive
scenarios in which they can embarrass
each other whoever they collectively
deem the loser of this competition after
10 events doesn't get to go to Paula
Abdul's party the trailer also gives a
few sneak peeks at some of the high
stakes humiliating situations including
one of the Joker's crawling out of a
cave resembling Gollum from the Lord of
the Rings they're also seen trying to
get somebody to help with a broken-down
car with a trunk full of drugs
and engaging in what appears to be a
horse bag gladiator ride and Joker's
fans will also appreciate Sal's Jaden
Smith tattoo making a cameo appearance
again all four members of the
tenderloins troop of co-written and
co-headlined the film Joseph Gatto James
Murray Brian Quinn and Salvatore vocano
you'll also spot producer and inside
joke sauce Casey Jost the rest of the
cast has filled out by both actors
playing people that Joker's meets during
their long voyage to Miami and random
strangers who happen to get poured into
the group-stage pranks at a 2018 San
Diego comic-con offense Brian Quinn
stated that the movie consists of 80% in
camera and 20% storyline however some
name actors do show up for cameo
appearances expect to see Impractical
Jokers after party host and former and
sing member Joey Fatone play a street
busker and Kane Hodder the man in the
Jason Voorhees hockey mask in multiple
Friday the 13th movies puts in an
appearance as an imposing bodyguard if
you want to catch up before the movie
debuted in February the show's latest
lates of episodes debuts on truTV on
Thursday January 30th this 9th season
will feature the 200th episode of
Impractical Jokers on February 13th
which will be set in Los Angeles about a
week later Impractical Jokers the movie
will begin rolling out to theaters
nationwide unfortunately for those who
want to know if they should bring their
kids the MPAA has yet to announce the
film's rating without being said there's
no reason to expect that Joker's
feature-length adventures to venture too
far beyond the bounds of all ages
entertainment will have to wait to find
out for sure but the show's antics are
in the pg-13 realm and fans should
expect the same from the film check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite TV shows are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the Bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]